hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Jessica Jones episode 13 video
all about the finale so in case you guys
haven't seen it just careful for
spoilers I know it seems like the series
has been out for a long time but it's
really only been a little bit more than
two weeks so for the most part I think
everybody that's like a hardcore comic
book fan has probably binge the whole
thing but just out of curiosity let me
know if any of your friends or anybody
in your family that you know is
intending to watch it it hasn't seen a
single episode yet the really big stuff
in this episode are it's kind of you
know pseudo daredevil crossover with
night nurse and killing off David
Tennant's character killing off kilgrave
I know it seems like he's dead I think
that's the intention he's dead and he's
not going to turn into some crazy zombie
that's gonna come back next week so we
just got to start by tipping our hat to
David Tennant saying you probably the
best Marvel villain from this past year
who actually wasn't that big of a
villain like in terms of spectacle like
when you think of big big villains you
think of Loki you think of the [ __ ] hour
you think of fan OHS but maybe a better
way to put it is that David Tennant was
the most compelling Marvel villain of
the year that's actually a really good
argument to have who's the better
villain killgrave or the kingpin because
they're both very relatable kilgrave is
your textbook narcissistic psychopath
who's obsessed with filling this hole
inside his soul
kingpin is just a person that's trying
to make his neighborhood a better place
he just happens to have some really big
morality issues so there's anything that
the Netflix series are doing way better
than the movies or any of the other TV
shows right now is giving us very real
villains with amazing character
development let the problem with the
2-hour movie is that you can do an
amazing built like Ultron is an amazing
villain James Spader had an amazing
performance but you get so little time
with him that some of the reasoning like
some of the reason why he gets really
pissed off at Tony Stark just doesn't
feel quite as real that's why I feel
like you know people who say that they
don't like Jessica Jones as much are
really just saying they like the movie
type of storytelling the way that they
tell stories in the movies better than
the way they tell the story on Jessica
Jones because Jessica Jones isn't really
a straight-up superhero show it's more
of a character study like a really
intense character study for a female
character with a certain measure of
superpower so just you know trying to
make her way in the world is this
gumshoe because there weren't a whole
lot of references to Marvel comics in
this last episode let's just work our
way through talk about daredevil things
in season 2 stuff like that you know
there's some light more
references especially with the IgH group
Simpsons character night nurse
daredevil defenders but really most of
the references that they had in this
were references to things that they're
only going to be addressing on jessica
jones in these Netflix series is not
stuff you're going to see in the movies
so Jessica takes Luke to the hospital
meets night nurse finds out that they're
all terrified of enhanced people and you
get the comedy of Jessica like picking
Luke up like a pile of laundry as night
nurses looking at her like oh my god WTF
am I getting into rosario Dawson was
amazing during daredevil season 1 but
she just proves the point like what an
amazing actor she is in these scenes
with Krysten Ritter with Jessica Jones
been-there-done-that lost Miley's she's
this totally normal badass nurse who's
completely over the idea of people with
powers like I mean she's a little
surprised at the idea of Luke having
super strong skin or kilgrave being able
to mind-control people but her reaction
to it all is just priceless
and then like it like at the end when
Luke Cage wakes up and she brings in the
water and realizes that he's gone she
just takes a drink sits down like it's
no big deal like up oh well whatever
this last episode like all these scenes
with night nurse in Jessica's apartment
with Luke Cage are some of the most real
moments in the entire series and how
awesome was it that the big badass dude
who you know you typically think would
be the one to try and save all the
damsels in distress' was passed out for
this entire episode it's just a nice way
that the series flips the genre on its
head like the Simpson character that was
kind of a misdirect with that character
like he had that savior complex where
he's like no Patsy this is too dangerous
I'm gonna take these pills and take care
of this problem for you and she's like
dude seriously don't do that
these Luke Cage scenes were just another
way of hammering that home like just
because you're the big strong dude with
superpowers doesn't mean you're just as
vulnerable as everyone else and just
because you're say like a female nurse
who says I'm not even a doctor you can
be just as helpful as someone with
superpowers and seriously how awesome
was that pop fiction moment where they
had to stab him through the eye total
Pulp Fiction uma Thurman he's gonna die
if we don't stick him with this needle
so let's talk about Luke Cage for a
second what's the deal now because his
series is coming really soon probably
next year we don't really have an exact
date for that but he's probably going to
be going to Harlem because he said the
Hell's Kitchen police are looking for
him and when he says I take care of me
and my own that's just the Heroes for
Hire tease he's just going to be helping
people in the way that Jessica Jones you
know that
kind of tease at the end with her
sitting on the desk listen to the
messages they're just going to start
helping more people now so if it wasn't
clear Luke Cage and Jessica aren't in a
relationship anymore so sometime around
the defender series they're gonna have
to make their peace with what they did
teach other Jessica killing Luke's wife
Luke almost killing Jessica while he was
mind control by killgrave so they both
done terrible things to each other that
they need to work off just in terms of
timing though I'm expecting Luke Cage in
the fall of next year like around the
same time that Jessica Jones dropped
this year so just looking at the Netflix
series we have daredevil season 2
starting in the spring that's going to
drop around Captain America Civil War
and then we're probably have Luke Cage
in the fall what about defenders and
Iron Fist though they said they're still
working on an Iron Fist series and they
have to introduce the character before
they do defenders so because they
haven't even started shooting iron fist
yet we're probably going to get that
series in 2017 maybe it like the
beginning of 2017 and then defenders
right after that so I'm not expecting
defenders to like summer of 2017 just
because I did it my other Jessica Jones
videos here's my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments what
was the craziest WTF moment for you in
the episode was it seeing what kilgrave
did to the people that he left behind in
that apartment the way he made his
father kill himself by cutting his arms
off making one of the dudes drink the
Drano making the other guy that survived
chop his father's arms up in the blender
probably the single most graphic moment
in this series if there was ever a
reason to not let your five-year-old
child watch this it would be for this
last episode like maybe you could show
him bits from Jessica Jones like oh hey
look at this female superhero this is
kind of fun then just pretend like the
episode is over like up that's it no
more one other big takeaway from this I
think is the way that superhero shows do
relationshipy stuff like you have
relationship drama because these are
real people they're going to get into
relationship so gonna have sex with
people Jessica talking to passed out
Luke probably the best superhero
relationship he's seen that I've seen
all year considering that we also had
Black Widow and Hulk we had night nurse
in daredevil which is also very real
relationship but then yet to consider
there's all the other superhero shows
there's like the DC TV shows let's
compare this very real relationship
moment to like the ham and cheese stuff
that you see on the flash now the flash
is meant to be more of a comic book show
it reads like an actual comic book so
the relationships are written as if
they're in an actual comic book I'll
just say that after seeing a lot of
comic book II relationship stuff Jessica
Jones is a free
breath of air season two Jessica Jones
what's going on though so they've said a
couple things like maybe it's not going
to happen just because of the timing
that's just because the time frame that
they have for defenders is so short they
like they just don't have the time to
work on season 2 now they haven't
confirmed anything but don't be
surprised if it doesn't happen till
after the defenders team-up series what
they said way back before daredevil
season 1 premiere is that some of the
series not all will get second seasons
and some of the characters they
introduced will be eligible for
spin-offs so that's where we get into
the Punisher spin-off series and they
are definitely gung-ho about that but no
idea when it's going to come maybe next
year at the earliest so we might
actually get a year with three separate
Netflix series at the same time
so let me know what you guys want to see
in season two if they end up doing it I
feel like the IgH is the easy sell
finding out what's going on with this
shadowy pharmaceutical company the game
Jessica her powers as well as will
Simpson with those special pills now the
team up with another character maybe
like a Jessica daredevil team-up or a
Jessica Luke Cage team-up she just fits
a little bit better with the Luke Cage
character just because of their
comic-book history because you can
totally crossover with any of the other
Netflix characters let's go work a case
for the Punisher so here's what's up I
have a behind-the-scenes Star Wars video
that I'm probably gonna be doing there's
been a whole lot of funny quotes from
some of the actors especially Lawrence
Kasdan who said I've written for Star
Wars movies and I don't know what the
term Canon means I don't know anything
about the Canon so I absolutely have to
talk about that it is way too funny to
not talk about be sure to subscribe to
get that video I'll try and post that
tonight but I also have some Game of
Thrones some Walking Dead some other
stuff I'm going to try and work on
Monday through Wednesday is going to be
really busy and Mark Hamill is coming
back to the flash this week if you
haven't seen I just posted a flash
trailer video so check that out just in
case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for that flash trailer with
Mark Hamill tricks or big rogue team-up
coming next week and you can click here
for all my other Jessica Jones Netflix
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you